FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
16 of the weekly Google
Could Platform podcast.
I am Francesc Campoy, and I'm
here with my colleague Mark.
Hey, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Hey.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Mark Mandel.
MARK MANDEL: Yes,
yes, that's my name.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: Oh, I'm good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Pretty good.
Happy to be back to work
on a Monday morning.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
but actually very
excited about the episode today.
We're going to have a lot
of Kubernetes, Kubernetes,
and more Kubernetes.
MARK MANDEL: And a
little bit of Kubernetes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yup, and we actually
have one of the
Kubernetes' people
that everybody associates
with Kubernetes,
really, Kelsey Hightower.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, very exciting.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
He's actually one
of our teammates in
the developer advocacy
group for Google Could
Platform, and he's
going to be talking about
Kubernetes, and especially
about Kubernetes 1.2,
the next version.
So we're going to be discussing
what is it, when it's coming--
MARK MANDEL: And it has some
super cool features that I
get really excited about.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, I know.
What we do is normally we
record the intro afterwords,
so we've just done
the interview.
And at some point, Mark actually
was basically jumping up happy.
So yeah, it's going to
be a very good interview.
And after that, we're also going
to be talking about Kubernetes.
Actually not only
Kubernetes, but maybe you
can explain a little bit.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so
we had a person who
sent us a message
on Reddit, talking
about having an
app-on-app engine
and possibly migrating it to
Kubernetes and Google Container
Engine and sort of some
pros and cons there.
So a little
discussion about that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So we'll
discuss that at the end.
But before that, we have
the cool thing of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, we do.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And the
cool thing of the week
is something that
you're going to be
explaining because you're very
involved with this project.
But apparently, we
have a Slack channel.
We have Slack
community, actually,
for Google Could Platform.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, we do.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Tell us
a little bit about it.
MARK MANDEL:
Excellent, so yeah, I
was quite involved in
getting this set up
with a few other
of our teammates--
Cindy, Ray, and Julia.
So if you're not
familiar with Slack,
Slack is a very popular
chat-for-work application.
It has all the usual chat
features of channels and rooms
and direct messaging
and stuff, but it's
become very, very popular.
What we also noticed was that
a lot of open source projects
and language
communities were already
setting up sort of Slack teams
for people to participate in.
I know you're on the Gophers one
and the stuff was also there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm in two
Slack communities, Gophers
and Google Cloud Platform.
MARK MANDEL: I'm in eight.
But yeah, we wanted a
place for-- a chat place
for people who use Google
Cloud Platform to use it,
and everyone was on Slack.
It's a low barrier to entry.
It's a really nice platform,
looks very pretty, too.
So we created a Google Cloud
Platform Slack community.
So yeah, if you're interested in
joining, it's bit.ly/gcp-slack,
link in the show notes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Exactly.
MARK MANDEL: Please
definitely come on down.
We've got obviously
a general chat room,
and we've got product
specific chat rooms.
It's a mix of people, right.
So it's a community platform.
It's public.
We have some
Googlers, but we have
a lot of Google Developer
experts in there as
well and just general users.
And it really is just
a place for community
to get together,
to help each other,
and really get to know
each other as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, I've been part
of the community for
quite a while now,
and I really like
it because it's
one of the most welcoming
communities I've
seen in a very long time.
People really ask beginner
questions, like hey, I
want to understand how
the Datastore works.
And people are really nice.
They point you to
the documentation.
They will answer any
questions you have,
so it's really, really cool.
And there is also
one of the channels
we have that are part of a
community, which I take very
personally-- and I like
very personally-- which
is the podcast channel.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, we have
a podcast channel there,
so if you want to
talk to Francesc
and I directly,
that is very true.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's a
very good way of doing it,
other than our many
other ways of doing it,
which maybe we'll say
at the end, maybe not.
Who knows?
Yeah, so if you want to join,
again, go to the show notes.
And we're going to have a link.
It's be bit.ly/gcp-slack.
MARK MANDEL: Definitely, yeah.
So I'd love to see you there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
I guess that now it's
time to welcome our
teammate Kelsey.
MARK MANDEL: Let's do it.
Today, I am very
pleased to announce
we have yet another special
guest to the podcast.
I'm very pleased
to announce that we
have Kelsey Hightower
joining us to talk
to us about Kubernetes today.
How are you doing today, Kelsey?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER:
I'm doing fantastic.
Any day is a good day if I
get to talk about Kubernetes.
MARK MANDEL:
Excellent, excellent.
Before we get stuck
into Kubernetes,
though, let's have a little bit
of a conversation about you.
I'm sure there are
very few people who
know who you are-- who don't
know who you are, I should say.
That was a terrible
faux pas on my part.
I'm sure there are
very few people who
don't know who you are,
but do you want to give us
a little background on
you, and who you are,
and what you do here at Google.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Yes,
I'm Kelsey Hightower,
you guys mentioned.
And I'm a very
pragmatic technologist.
I like things that work,
less about the buzz
and more about the
practicality of doing things.
So my background is
mainly as a sysadmin.
maybe the last six years, I
kind of made the transition
to being a developer.
I manage development
teams, I manage ops teams,
and part of my career
has grown into doing
a lot of public speaking
and advocating for things
that work, which has me now
here at Google pretty much doing
the best of what I do
around Google Cloud Platform
and really a technology
such as Kubernetes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great, yeah,
I remember the first time
I saw you.
That was, I think it was
two years ago at GopherCon.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Yes, that was
the most epic talk of my life.
You're trying to do a Go
talk in front of the Go team,
and they're looking at all
your slides for syntax errors.
That is not the funnest
thing in the world.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, that
was an amazing talk, though,
really, really fun times.
MARK MANDEL:
Excellent, excellent.
OK, well, why don't
we dive right in.
We were talking
about Kubernetes.
We have had Brian Dorsey on to
talk about Kubernetes as well,
but I'd love to get your take
on it like what is Kubernetes,
what does it mean to
you, especially for you
the people that
haven't listened to it,
or just want an
alternate perspective.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Yeah,
when I look at Kubernetes
or when it first came out, the
way I viewed Kubernetes was
more of a collection
of ideas that
have been brewing
from various angles
in the industry in general.
So outside of Google,
the perspective
was everyone should be doing
some form of automation, right?
Well, there's Puppet,
Schaeffer, Antible,
and while a lot of those tools
got a lot of people very far,
I would claim that the
abstractions were wrong.
We were basically
wrapping automation tools
around low-level
things that were never
designed to work together,
like SSH and package managers.
You can script those things,
but there were just so
many extractions we
were dealing with.
And then when you
look at Kubernetes,
it looks like over time,
some of the best practices
that people have been doing on
the outside world, of course,
mixed with a lot of
things that Google
has been doing internally,
really just streamlines
all of that stuff.
So if you look at
it, Kubernetes to me
just looks like a
checkpoint in where
we are with automation today.
I think will become the
new baseline for how people
do things going
forward, and I think
it's going to be a new
set of abstractions.
So I don't see Kubernetes
as the end game.
I kind of see it
as the next level
that people will be
automating against, a new set
of primitives, new
set of abstractions.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
All right, so let's maybe even
take it to a higher level.
If I'm a new user, I've
never heard of Kubernetes.
I don't know what it is.
I don't know what it does.
How would you give
me the 30,000 foot
view of what that looks like?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: I think when
you talk about Kubernetes,
you start with the application.
So with config management
and other tools,
you start with the
server, and you kind of
build it up from there.
I think with
Kubernetes, we assume
that Kubernetes is installed
and that you have a set of APIs
for deploying your app.
So once you focus
on your app, then
we start to push in
barriers like, hey,
how do you package that app?
The abstraction we
use is containers,
so you're going to wrap
your app in a container.
Once you have it in a
container, then you're
just going to
express how you need
it to run, how many
copies does it need to do,
what zones does
it need to run in,
and some basic high
level networking things.
How do people hit
your application?
That's the goal with Kubernetes.
Start with the app.
End with the app.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
So you seem to be involved
with the Kubernetes
project for quite a while now.
From my history, from
seeing you speak,
it seems like you've
been doing it forever.
How did you get involved
with Kubernetes?
What's the history of that?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: The
history of Kubernetes
is a pretty
interesting, actually.
So at the time I was
working at CoreOS.
And at CoreOS, we
were building what
we like to describe as Google's
infrastructure for everyone
else.
And that's a tall order
just because no one
has Google infrastructure
except for Google.
But we did a pretty good job of
delivering the whole OS that's
focused on containers, and
as we moved up the stack,
we built the tool called fleet.
And fleet used to talk
to etcd, which etcd
was a clone of another
internal Google service.
And fleet was in its infancy
at the time, I would say.
It was definitely
very high level.
You can get basic things done.
And then one day we're all
watching the Doctor Khan
webcast where Brendan
unveils Kubernetes basically
to everyone.
And at that point
in time, I just
knew that was the way going
forward, that things like Fleet
and all the low-level
docker script-y
tools would be no match for
that way of doing things.
And I think that night
I downloaded Kubernetes
and no documentation,
and really figured out
how to get it
deployed, and wrote
one of the first,
probably, outside of Google
blog posts about Kubernetes.
It was a full tutorial.
You guys did a PR release, which
is a thing big companies do.
And we did this nice little
single-node Kubernetes
how-to guide.
And you guys got number
two on Hacker News.
We ended up at number one,
so we were really proud
about that move.
It was kind of a ninja
move from the start-ups.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm curious
about-- you mentioned
that etcd was also a part
of the Google infrastructure
for everyone else.
What project could
it be internally?
Could you explain
a little bit more
about what etcd
really is for people
that have never heard about it?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Yes, so etcd
is basically a key value pair
storage server.
A lot of people will
compare to Redis,
but I guess they were thinking
about it the wrong way.
Ideally, it's modeled
after the Chubby paper,
so as an internal
service Google uses,
that has stronger
guarantees on consistency.
So a lot of people
do question, hey,
why do I need such
strong consistency
when most applications don't
really have that requirement?
But etcd provides essentially
two things if you really
think about it.
It's a place to store
your configurations,
so ideally, configurations
would be a list of backends
that a group of web
servers need to know about.
So ideally, you want
all of those web servers
to agree on what the
backend should be, right?
Maybe they don't necessary have
the same list at the same time,
but they should be
guaranteed that if they all
agree on a single point
in time that they should
have the same list of backends.
So it's a configuration
store, ideally
for application configs.
So etcd is not designed to
store gigs and gigs of data.
So I think early on, people were
storing image blobs in etcd,
and--
MARK MANDEL: Oh no.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER:
Yeah, they really
love the high
availability features
of etcd, which is rooted in
a consensus algorithm called
raft.
So raft is really nice because
it automates the membership,
leader election, and failover.
So this is very
nice when you start
to think in terms
of data stores where
it's really painful to set
up a cluster of databases
and then handle adding
and removing nodes.
Things like etcd
that rely on raft
pretty much automate most
of that process for you,
so of course, everyone wants
to use it for everything.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
And I don't know,
I might be wrong.
But is Kubernetes based on etcd?
Is it using it somewhere?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Yeah so,
that was one nice thing
about when Kubernetes came out.
It relied on a couple
of leading projects,
so it picked docker-fork
container runtime instead
of Google shipping their own.
And it also leveraged etcd,
so all of those principles
we just talked about
were a perfect fit
for writing a cluster
manager like Kubernetes.
And it really gave
people that feel
that they were getting something
really close to what we have
internally, [INAUDIBLE] and
Chubby, that combination just
goes together.
And now we have an open
source combination as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That is very cool.
So you mentioned
that Kubernetes,
when it was created,
it was built
on top of etcd and Docker, but
you were working on a CoreOS,
and CoreOS also had
this different format
for containers, rkt?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Yes,
actually Kubernetes
came out before rkt
was released, actually.
So when Kubernetes came out,
it was all built around Docker
and I would say, at that
time, I think a lot of people
were rallying behind Docker.
And it definitely fit the bill.
At CoreOS, the drive for
alternative container format
probably started what we
now call the container wars.
But there's this idea that
the container runtime should
be super small and focused,
and that container runtime that
was built at CoreOS is
definitely called rkt.
And rkt was designed to
pretty much work well
with something like Kubernetes.
So rkt doesn't have
a centralized daemon.
We rely on something
like Kubernetes for that.
rkt also has a concept
of pods, so this
is a new notion
introduced by Kubernetes
that in order to
compose applications
in the way that would be
easy to schedule and manage,
you would need to
be able to put more
than one container
in a container
that you could
schedule atomically.
So the idea is that
many applications--
I know sometimes I'll end up
working with a node JS app,
and it needs something
like nginx to sit on top.
So pods give you a
kind of an easy way
of putting those two things
together and shipping them
around.
It really gives people
that virtual machine feel.
You can push these
things out the same way
you've been managing VMs in
your infrastructure today.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
So yeah, that gives
us a little bit
of an idea of how
Kubernetes came to be
and what it really is, but
imagine that I'm creating
my start up and I'm considering
using Kubernetes or maybe
other tools, what could
be the other tools
that I might consider
and why should I
use Kubernetes and
not something else?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: This
comes up quite a bit,
so I think when I usually
talk about Kubernetes--
it's like if you think
Heroku was a good idea,
but it's a little
too restrictive.
And you want to
walk one step back,
so maybe you can have a
little bit more choice
on where you host it, what
type of things you can run.
So if I look at Kubernetes,
I'd say it's maybe
one or two steps below a pass.
So if you're a start up looking
to deploy your application
and you really are not trying
to build out a full ops team
or deal with a ton
of infrastructure,
then Kubernetes gives
you the right set of APIs
to say, hey, look I
don't mind packaging
my things in containers, but
I do want some flexibility
over the runtime.
So things like
Heroku would probably
have some restrictions on
what run-times you can run
or what libraries
you could use, and we
have the same set of
restrictions on the side of app
engine, right?
So the idea there is
that in order for us
to do all the automatic
behind-the-scenes,
we have to introduce
some constraints,
and those are shared
multi-tenant platforms.
So with Kubernetes,
since you kind of run
that on your own
cluster of machines,
gives you the flexibility
to run it where you want,
even though our competitors
do have the ability
to run Kubernetes, it's a
design goal of Kubernetes
that you can run it on
your laptop, your data
center, or inside the cloud.
And if you're a startup, that
may be interesting to you.
Maybe you get started on
a Mac mini in the office
and decide to push it
to the cloud later,
and you have the flexibility
of packaging anything you want.
So if you want to have a bunch
of security vulnerabilities
running on an old
version of Java,
you totally can do
that in Kubernetes.
We do not force
you down any path,
but yeah, I think
people like that.
It's the flexibility.
MARK MANDEL: That makes sense.
That makes sense.
This is a leading
question, but as
someone who has spent much
of the last little while
setting up clusters
of Kubernetes,
where is your favorite place
to get started with Kubernetes?
So getting it set off.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: I
honestly, at this point,
I just tell people that you
need to click the GKE button.
It sounds like we're
coping out here,
but what I'm starting
to understand
is that a lot of people love
this idea that Kubernetes
is this open source project.
It is a rare case that a
cloud provider provides
the same thing that
they run and charge
customers for as a free thing
that they can download and run
on their own gear.
That's pretty amazing.
So of course, the first
thing people want to do
is to deploy it themselves.
And it's like, well, you have
to make a lot of decisions here,
so I don't want to talk
too bad about OpenStack,
but I could never get
OpenStack deployed.
So there are a lot of
moving pieces in OpenStack.
I think Kubernetes is far
easier to deploy than OpenStack
is, mainly because we don't have
to deal with the physical world
underneath.
We assume we have a node
abstraction in place.
But there's a lot to
managing a cluster,
and I think a lot of people that
are interested in Kubernetes
want to manage applications.
So this is why I say, hey,
look cut your teeth on GKE,
learn the Kubernetes'
API, and then
have that sit down discussion
where you talk about topology,
where you want to
run Kubernetes.
Do you want to run it
in your own gear, maybe
a different could provider?
But I don't think
the right way to get
started with Kubernetes,
in my opinion,
if you're interested in
deploying applications,
is to go through all of
the work of deciding how
you want to deploy Kubernetes.
So with that said, we
do have to kube-up,
so there is a script for those
that do want a single command.
You can use it.
MARK MANDEL: And
by GKE, I just want
be clear for those
people who are listening,
that's Google Container Engine.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And we
use GKE for two reasons.
One is the C was already taken.
GCE is already Compute
Engine, and then
the K also stands
for Kubernetes.
MARK MANDEL: There
you go, so yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
wanted to add on the fact
that you mentioned that you
can run Kubernetes basically
anywhere you want, and for
those that have not seen it,
one of our teammates, Ray Tsang,
created this really cool demo,
collaborating with
someone in Jfokus,
where they were
running Kubernetes
in a data center made
of five Raspberry Pi's,
all on the table.
So that's pretty cool.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER:
Yeah, I mean, I
think that's the biggest
selling point for people
with Kubernetes, that we
finally have-- I would probably
say like the first cloud OS
because when I think about what
could Kubernetes does,
it's more than just
deploying applications.
It provides that nice
abstraction over storage.
It normalizes the
cloud providers
where you don't have to deal
with the individual API calls.
But you get Kubernetes
up and running,
you can almost target
that going forward.
MARK MANDEL: That
makes a lot of sense.
I like that a lot.
It levels the playing
field to a degree.
It's like who's going to give
the best Kubernetes experience?
And really then, just the
consumer wins out of everyone.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER:
But you know what,
since we're on this podcast,
I think the most thing
that I think when people
start to look at Kubernetes,
I hope that they see this as
an opportunity to pay back
some of that technical debt.
You know what I mean?
So a lot of people
that have issues
with adopting a platform
like Kubernetes,
like having an
automated scheduler that
can move your application around
at any point in the day by far
is the biggest barrier.
But it's only a barrier
because a lot of people
have built up so
much technical debt
on assuming that
applications only get
deployed to specific machines.
And if that machine
goes down, people
run around wearing
pagers and all of this,
and I think this is probably
the right time to sit down
and say, look, there's a limit.
There are small
amounts of things
we could do to make our apps
fit really well in this world.
And I think a lot of people use
the word legacy as a barrier
to say, hey, we can't use
this new stuff because we
have these legacy apps.
And the truth is, I think
it's really simple for people
to make small changes, either
to log the standard out,
retry database connections
before segfaulting.
Things like that you can
easily do in these applications
regardless of when
you wrote them
that will make them a much
better fit for running
in something like Kubernetes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
Before we move to
the next topic,
I wanted to know
a little bit more
about how this logging worked.
You mentioned that rather
than segfaulting or just
like just failing, your
program should log something.
Is there some specific library
that people should use,
or it's just like
logging to standard error
and just hope for the best?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER:
Yeah, so Kubernetes
is like-- I guess
Heroku probably
set the stage for this.
Part of the team at Heroku
wrote the 12 factor manifesto,
and it was this idea
that when you're
dealing with a more
capable platform,
you don't necessarily need to
write to your own log files,
mainly because
there's no guarantee
that you even have access
to write to the disk.
And it also reduces where
we can run containers
and how we restrict them.
So the idea with logging is that
if we follow some of the things
that you see in the
12 factor manifesto--
I think it's like 12factor.net--
it talks about logging.
And the simplest thing you
can do, and the best practice,
is just simply log
the standard out.
So pretty much no
special libraries
needed, no syslog libraries.
You don't need to really
deal with integrating
with elastic search or
any of those things.
All you really need to do
is log the standard out,
and allow the platform
to aggregate those logs
and send them to
a central source,
or provide the structuring
required to query them later.
So that's the nice thing
about this new movement
around 12 factor style
applications, standard out.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That is very cool.
So I think that we should
talk a little bit about one
of the reasons why we have you
in the podcast today, which
is not only because
you're awesome
but also because the next
version of Kubernetes--
Kubernetes 1.2, it's going
to be released very soon.
So could you tell us
a little bit about it?
What is coming on?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: So I
think Kubernetes really
represents what happens
when an open source
project gets popular.
You start to get a
lot more contributors.
You start to get people
running it in the production.
And the details that come out
of that is what 1.2 represents.
So there's been a lot of
work on improving the way
we do deployments, so in
Kubernetes, everything
is modeled with an object.
So if you want to
have a service,
you want to deploy
a set of containers,
they all have their own API
object that describes them.
So one of the patterns that
we saw a lot of people really
engaged in with
Kubernetes was things
like rolling updates and this
idea of describing something
that can be scaled easily using
what we call a replication
controller, which
was a babysitter
over a set of containers.
So what we did with
that particular pattern
is we entered this
deployment object,
so deployments become this first
class thing in Kubernetes 1.2
that will allow you to
describe your update policy,
your scaling requirements,
all in a single object.
And that single
object will basically
abstract a lot of lower
level things from people
and be much easier to work with.
So Kubernetes also
introduces the config map.
So a lot of things we saw a lot
of people doing in Kubernetes
1.1 and 1.0 was using
what we call secrets,
so secrets was a way to store
configuration key values
and present them to the
application at runtime.
They were designed for
secrets, but since that
was the only mechanism to do
late binding of configuration
and applications, we
introduced this thing called
config map, which
was really designed
to allow the application to be
notified when there's changes.
So if you use config
maps instead of secrets,
very similar APIs, you can
store not only key value pairs,
but you can expose them as
environment variables, or files
on disk, and also notify
the actual machine
that the configuration
has changed.
So those are the two
big things that I like.
MARK MANDEL: That's awesome!
I haven't been keeping as
up-to-date with Kubernetes
as I should be, and
the fact that you
can to config maps to
environment variables
was a huge pain point for me,
so I'm super happy to hear that.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Oh,
and also the tooling.
So some of the small things a
lot of people don't talk about
is the tooling has
improved greatly,
so now I'll walk
you through what
it took to create a secret.
Before you used to
have to base 64 encode
some file into a key
value, but now you
can actually automate
that on the command line.
So you can run [INAUDIBLE]
create secrets,
name the secret, and
then dash dash from file.
And it would do all
those things for you
and store them as the
file name automatically,
and all you have
to do is reference
that file name
when you reference
the secrets in
your pod manifest.
So that's just cut down just
on a ton of work for end users.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: That
just made me so happy.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: I see Mark
over here smiling big time,
and I think a lot
of people will, too,
because of a lot
of these features
are just straight up
removing friction.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
that's phenomenal.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, that is great.
I was a little bit curious
about how is Kubernetes managed,
meaning that these features
that have been added
are clearly something
that the community wanted,
or least mark wanted.
Is it really
community management?
What do I do if I something
to be added to the community,
to the Kubernetes?
Do I follow bug?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Yeah, so the
nice thing about Kubernetes
is it's completely
run on GitHub.
So it's one of the rare projects
where the issues and the code
are all managed on
GitHub, so we basically
follow the standard workflow
that most projects hosted
on GitHub follow.
If you want something changed,
you can open an issue,
and we're not very
strict on how much detail
you need to put in that issue.
People on the Kubernetes
community will do a lot of work
reproducing your issue
or giving a response.
But if you wanted to
add a new feature,
you start with an issue.
Someone will either
search the other issues
that are open to see if
that feature is already
slated to go.
We do keep a public
roadmap of milestones,
so we're already
actively planning 1.3.
I think that some few issues
have already been tagged.
And then we collaborate
with the users.
So if you submitted
something, we do solicit help.
So we do welcome
code contributions.
There are people help
review your code.
There's also lots
of collaboration
from companies like Waway,
and Red Hat, and CoreOS.
Those three companies are
doing a lot with their users
to satisfy those requests,
so it's very much
a collaborative project.
You pop over to GitHub,
and we make things happen.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome, that
sounds pretty egalitarian.
So we're slowly running out
of time here a little bit.
Here are a couple of
final questions for you.
I want to ask, what's the
coolest thing you've seen
somebody build on Kubernetes?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER:
The coolest thing
I've seen someone
build on Kubernetes
was probably about a year ago.
I was giving a Kubernetes
workshop in Portland,
and there was a company locally
in town-- Jive Software.
And they showed up, and they're
like, let us show you our demo.
And they show me this
dashboard, and the dashboard
was pretty clean.
They were using every single
Kubernetes feature at the time,
including things like secret.
So what you could
do on their platform
was you could kick off a
three-tier application,
and when you deployed
the database,
it would automatically
generate its own secret
and store it in Kubernetes.
And the web applications
would wait for that secret
to show up and then
use that secret
to connect to the database.
So they basically built
their own platform
that would automate the thing
like creation of data stores
and passwords without
a human intervention.
And I thought that was really
clever because they did that
with no permission from
the Kubernetes team,
but the APIs were just awesome
enough for them to pull it off.
So it was a nice little web UI.
I figured, man, I wish that
was an open source project.
So that was pretty cool.
MARK MANDEL: That does
sound pretty cool.
Awesome.
And as a final question,
is there anything here
you want to mention
that we haven't
had a chance to mention yet?
I'm sure there's a lot we
could talk about, but--
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: I
think a lot of people,
when it comes to Kubernetes,
I want people to understand
that it's not a pass.
It's not a platform.
It's a service.
It's very much a--
I like to think
of it as a scripting in an
environment for developers
and sysadmins.
So if you want to have
your perfect platform,
I think Kubernetes is the
perfect place to start.
You should feel
comfortable building
your own tools,
your own deployment
workflows, your own schedulers.
Kubernetes is designed to
have multiple schedulers.
We do ship one out of the box.
But you see a lot
of robust schedulers
coming from companies like
Univa with their grid engine.
You'll see a lot more
coming down the pipe.
But think of it as an open
platform for the modern age.
Anything you can
think of automating,
consider doing that
on top of Kubernetes
in our rich set of APIs.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
Well, thank you so much for
being here with us today.
I learned a lot.
I'm actually very excited
about the new version.
I have used Kubernetes a
little bit but fully not enough
to as excited as Mark
was about config maps.
But I'm sure that lots of
people are going to be excited
and are going to appreciate
your help, so thank you so much.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Awesome.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks
a lot, Kelsey.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
thank you so much,
Kelsey, for an
amazing interview.
I learned personally
a lot, and I
know I'm very excited about
most of the new features coming.
MARK MANDEL: I totally can't
wait to play with config maps.
I'm very excited.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You are
really excited about it.
It's a pity we're not recording
this because he was literally
jumping.
So, anyway, before we finish, we
have our question of the week.
And I think that you
saw that question first,
so I'm going to let you
explain what the question was.
MARK MANDEL: Sure, so the
user on Reddit is Prebenl.
Thank you so much
for providing us
this question, which is great.
Thank you so much for that.
I think it's actually
quite interesting.
So the question is, "Hi.
I'm very excited about
Google Container Engine
and think it would suit
some of my projects well.
One thing stopping us from
moving away from App Engine
is that we depend on the
search or indexing API,
and as far as I can see,
there's no external API
available for that yet.
I can't find any
information about it,
but are there any plans
to open this service up
to applications residing
outside of App Engine
like you did with
Cloud Datastore?"
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool, that's
actually a very good question.
Unfortunately, one
of the things that--
the first part of the answer
is going to be we cannot really
discuss roadmaps, so we cannot
say if it is coming or not.
But regardless of that
API being available or not
in the future,
outside of a benching,
something that could be
interesting to consider
is, well, why do you really
need to move from app engine
to compute engine-- sorry,
to Container Engine.
And do you really need to?
And if you need to,
it's not a 100% thing
that you need to
move completely.
So what do you think?
MARK MANDEL: So yeah, we
were talking about this a bit
before, and I think it's
a completely valid point.
You don't have to
lift and shift,
which seems to be a very
particular term that
comes up a lot
now, but you don't
have to take your whole thing.
There's a couple of ways
you can go about this.
For one instance,
if you needed to,
you could just expose the parts
that are using your search
API, through app engine as
a rest endpoint or something
similar and access it that way.
And then if you needed to access
that from Container Engine,
for example, that would
be pretty easy to do.
It's all inside Google's
network, super fast.
You could totally do that.
But if you don't want
to or don't really
need to move your
application off app engine,
it's working well,
there's no real reason to.
But you need, say, maybe
the power of flexibility
of Container Engine for
something specific, again,
you could just move
that particular part
to Container
Engine, maybe expose
that as a REST
endpoint or something
similar, leverage it that way.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, I totally agree.
And actually, my
first reaction, if I
had something that
is already running
a mere successful on
app engine, and it
had something that
for some reason,
like I want to use some
specific library like FFmpeg
or something that will
not run on app engine,
my first move could be
consider managed VMs.
So if that's a
reason why you think
about moving to
Kubernetes, probably I
could consider
managed VMs first just
because it's going to be
really easy for you to migrate.
If you actually want to move to
Kubernetes for other reasons--
like because it's really cool,
which it is-- what I could
consider is exactly
what Mark said,
what depends really
on the search
API, the search or
indexing API, could
be kept as a simple rest API.
So something really
simple that you
have just running
there and it just
being accessed as an external
service from your Kubernetes
cluster.
So I think that's actually
a pretty good idea.
We are not like a container
engine and compute engine--
yeah, Container Engine, compute
engine, app engine, managed VM,
and so on.
We talk about it during
one of the first episodes,
about how it's a continuum.
And it's not only
about the fact that you
have to be in one of those
ranges of how much freedom
or how much management you
want to have, but it's also you
can just pick and choose for
every single one of the parts
of your system and just spread
it all over that continuum.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it is about finding
the right tool for the
right job and finding
the thing that's going to fit
well for what you need to do.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And if we
didn't answer your question
correctly because you wanted
to know something specifically,
feel free to send
another message.
We love your messages.
MARK MANDEL: We love
receiving messages,
and thank you to
everyone who listens.
And thank you everyone
who participates.
We really do appreciate it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I think
that it's time to go again.
So where are you
going to be next week?
MARK MANDEL: Next
week-- oh my god, I
just started freaking out.
So next week, I will be at GDC.
I'll be at the Game
Developers Conference.
Super excited about that.
If you're going
to be there, we'll
be doing a developer
day on day one.
I'll be hosting a
roundtable or two there,
talking about how
you can use Cloud--
sort of in a discussion, how you
can use Cloud to basically do
interesting things
with your game,
how can it really change
the game you're building.
And also we'll be down at the
Google booth, the Google Cloud
Platform section of
the Google booth.
I'll be there probably
most of the time.
So please definitely
drop by, would
love to talk to you about game
development and the Cloud.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: And yourself?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Well, yeah.
If you're freaking
out, I don't know
how to describe how
I'm feeling right now.
But I will be in Austin at
the beginning of the week
until the end of
South by Southwest.
We're going to be running a
bunch of parties, and events,
and lots of fun, and lots of
work, also in the fiber space.
So if you're around
Austin, come say hi.
I'm very happy to
share our demos.
Actually, we're going to have
a couple really cool demos.
Cloud Spin's going to be there.
MARK MANDEL: Nice, we'll
have Cloud Spin, too.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, we're going
to also have a very cool
demo that we have not
spoken about it yet, I think,
which is the VisionBot.
MARK MANDEL: VisionBot.
Oh, we should talk about that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We
should talk about that.
Yeah, we should have Caz
maybe, and interview him
about the demo.
And after that, I will probably
be at GDC, helping you,
but also I'll be at Droidcon,
which is at the same time,
also trying to help people.
And then on Saturday
19th, we're actually
running a training session
on Google Cloud Platform,
so it's CP100.
And it's going to be down in
Mountain View for the Silicon
Valley iOS meet up.
MARK MANDEL: OK, you win.
You win.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, that's going
to be-- my god, that's
going to be fun.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, Yeah,
did you want to slate that?
I don't think you're--
you're not allowed to slate .
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Nah, nah, not needed.
Anyway, I think it's
going to be fun.
It's going to be a
fun week next week.
So again, thank you
Mark for being here
and helping with this episode.
MARK MANDEL: Thank
you to you as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
thank you do our listeners
to be so many of them.
We started to have a
decent amount of listeners,
but we're not getting enough
messages in my opinion.
So please, send
us more messages.
MARK MANDEL: Definitely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What
you like, what you
don't like, what do you
want us to talk about.
MARK MANDEL: Either via email,
via Reddit, via Google+,
or even by the Slack channel.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Or
Twitter, or yeah,
many, many ways to contact us.
Anyway, thank you so much.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
talk to you next week.
MARK MANDEL: See you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]